where do we stand on Pee-wee Herman he
got got beat off in a movie theater
around a bunch of dudes in a porn movie
theater he was doing what every other
man in the row was doing I get it he was
being weird he was PeeWee but he's
Peewee Herman's are like oh yeah you
can't be Peewee you can't be PeeWee
Herman in here yeah put a hood on yeah
you talk to couches and [__] man
on a couch I don't care what year it is
though going to a theater and beating
off of the room full of people's insane
yo it was a boring theme
that's what they used to do it's a porn
theater could you imagine that's our
dude you should go to hook up with each
other hey what's up hey what's up dude
that was the thing it's like a it's like
a bath okay yeah yeah naked it's not a
regular [__] Regal no
is
AMC party no there's no Jujubes in
[__] Sour Patch Kids mixed in with
dicks
you got water and pull your dick that's
about it you get